foreign
welcome to the Xbox games showcase
extended my name is Tina amini and I'm
here to dive a little bit more into the
games you saw at our recent Xbox game
showcase
showcase featured 27 ambitious games all
coming to Xbox games like clockwork
Revolution from nxl entertainment Fable
from playground games and from our
partners Star Wars Outlaws from Ubisoft
massive in collaboration with lucasfilm
games and kunitsugami Casa the Goddess
from Capcom today we'll take a closer
look at some other games from our
showcase lineup and introduce you to
some more games too we've got the game
director of a vowed from Obsidian
Entertainment breaking down the game's
trailer and the game director of Hi-Fi
Rush from Tango Gameworks is here to
tell us about their newest update you'll
also hear from Sarah Bond Head of the
gaming ecosystem Organization for Xbox
we'll tell us more about a program to
bring games from underrepresented
developers with unique Visions to Xbox
and Game Pass and we may just have a few
other fun guests in store for you too so
stay tuned but first let's check out the
Rainy Streets and Sinister markets of
cyberpunk 27 27 Phantom Liberty
hello everyone I'm really excited to
welcome you to this exclusive Xbox store
over Black Market one of the locations
in Dogtown that you are going to be able
to explore in cyberpunk 2077 Phantom
Liberty
as you can see Dogtown welcomes you with
an open arms
this is Black Market a location where
you as a player as a mercenary you can
obtain unique cyberware and weapons
things that you cannot find anywhere in
this world dog town is a part of night
City but has its own very distinct look
and Vibe it's outside of the
jurisdiction of ncpd attracting all
kinds of eccentrics and dangerous
characters
radical mods
or seen anything like that on a non-mail
stroller
check this out
we have put a lot of work into making
the world feel more alive small scenes
secrets to find Easter eggs make this
place feel more vibrant and more
believable
but what's inescapable in Dogtown is
Kurt Hansen Kurt is a leader of borgas
militia who rules dockdown of an iron
fist you've gone to the right place
in Dogtown I keep your business safe as
long as you abide by my rules they're
really nice guy as you can see
Black Market also is a place where you
can find new illegal weapons and goods
they are some of the most powerful items
in the world but are often much more
dangerous to use and use cyberware
capacity system which leads you to push
your body to the Limit and give you new
abilities to deliver more thrilling
gameplay experiences like the air Dash
or the ability to see the enemies
through the walls or change your
appearance to lose the Heat
August is the authorities of Dogtown and
they are more dangerous than ncpd when
you as a player commit crimes in Dogtown
they are the guys who are going to chase
you we have completely overhauled the
police system
instructions are more believable Dynamic
and diverse the team has been working
passionately to deliver you more deeper
and meaningful experience and I really
cannot wait for you to find out more
this September
see you in Dogtown
we're not done talking about CD projekt
Red's next dive into the story between V
and Johnny just yet in fact we're here
with the voice and stylings of Johnny
silverhand Keanu Reeves himself welcome
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
likewise well Phantom Liberty introduces
us to an entirely new location in night
City it's called Dogtown it's this
devastated place it's controlled by a
militia but I think you know more about
it than I do so how would you describe
it to players night city has its own
kind of
levels to it and I think dog town is
kind of going down to a darker place
um
it's dystopian
it has attention to it and
this under current of kind of violence
you know like and struggle
you know
can I swear yeah shit's gone down
in dog town oh I like that tagline yeah
and it's just you know I mean hopefully
it'll be fun for people to uh
to play there
it's hard to believe that there's an
underbelly to the underbelly yes that is
night city right yeah you're a little
scared no it's a good way I mean we're
all kind of drawn to we're all Moths To
The Flame aren't we and there's a lot of
flame and dark time well if anyone could
take it on it's V so that certainly
gives me the confidence yeah Visa
Survivor exactly oh yeah you know and we
just saw a tour of Dogtown too so we got
a little bit of that Ambiance and we can
see what the environment is like people
are getting beat up it's not good it's
man it's not the friendliest place to be
you gotta you gotta be prepared for it
truly yeah but in our tour we also hear
a recording from a colonel Kurt Hansen
who's this guy because he seems pretty
dangerous too yeah that guy no I'm sorry
I can't say that my inner Johnny came
out I think that's good we know the tone
now yeah well I mean he's ex-military
military too ruthless power hungry
manipulative and Johnny doesn't like him
I
like I mean night City in general is the
kind of place that breeds that kind of
character yeah let's take a step back
let's talk about Johnny as a person
instead of this horrible person known as
Colonel Kurt Hanson I don't know about
this guy but people like Johnny and I
think it's interesting because we know
him to be opinionated he's radical we've
seen that in cyberpunk 2077 in the main
campaign but as we get to know him he's
got a sensitive side too he can actually
be quite caring oh that's what makes it
so much fun he is outspoken he is a
little grumpy and he has a right to be
he's been used he's been abused he's
been abandoned and I think that through
that kind of hardness of his outside
there is a vulnerability to him and I
think what's great about it is I I get
to play that character in so many
different ways and so the range him at
his school especially for the player you
get to see these moments in flashbacks
you start to understand he's a product
of his upbringing truly of his
surrounding well let's not get carried
away I mean I mean we can start talking
about nature and nurture
I'm sorry I keep dropping into Johnny
but uh
um
yeah I like I like his anger
I like his passion I like what he stands
for he's
he's really just looking for a fair shot
and I I love that he's kind of going
through music that there's an artist
side to him and
you know I got some great speeches
there's all these moments with Johnny
where a tiny little thing you know
elicits this really fun response you can
flip him off and he double Birds you
back like I love those kind of moments
or Rock
so as somebody who's very familiar with
Thrillers because you've started in a
few
what do you think about Phantom Liberty
makes for a good spy Thriller in
particular
the quest to understand what's going on
so and and the kind of scavenger hunt of
information
the mystery the double crossing what is
true what's fiction what can you count
on you can't count on anything that is
really kind of Amplified
well thank you so much for coming out to
another Xbox presentation you've got a
lot of fans out there in the Xbox
community so I think I can speak for all
of us and saying we really appreciate
you showing up here today oh well thank
you
well before I close things out I love
your help here at Keanu how do you think
Johnny would end this interview right
now
well there's a lot of ways you could do
that
but uh Tina pleasure to meet you oh is
that how Johnny would do it yeah oh
thank you Johnny such a pleasure to have
you out I thought you were going to kick
down the camera or something so no you
see he's respectful you know you're a
good egg oh thank you you too and I'll
see you out there again soon
thank you
[Music]
oh I'm so sorry for dragging you all
into this
[Music]
[Laughter]
the world you think you live in
doesn't exist
and if you got a glimpse behind the
scenery
the stage cry
you will discover nothing but darkness
and once perceived it will swallow you
whole
I'm in a race against this Darkness a
race to locate an ancient ruin a tower
of unspeakable power I need the best of
the best
[Music]
all dead
all dead so I'll use you
Scoundrels
thieves
Cutthroats the best of the worst
[Music]
oh come now try not to look so glove
you're going to help me save the world
thank you
when it comes to RPG Studios Obsidian
Entertainment is among the very best
from Fallout New Vegas and the outer
worlds to Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic II and pentiment obsidian games
have placed their stamp on the genre
joining us today for a closer look at
about is game director Carrie Patel
Kerry I am so excited to have you here
we just saw this big reveal of a vowed
and there's so many little bits of
information in there that I want to dig
out and pick your brain around but
before we get into all that I'm assuming
that you don't need to have played
pillars one or two to really get into a
vowed you're absolutely right you don't
need to have played pillars one or two
you can come to the world of avowed
fresh we want this to be a welcoming
experience to new players but if you are
a returning fan there are some
recognizable tidbits for people who have
played pillars one or two can you tease
any more of just those General
connections to the universe and no Major
Spoilers of course yeah there are a
couple returning characters that players
might recognize from dead fire in
particular players who have played the
original games will recognize some of
the parts of the world and some of the
factions the adirin Empire plays pretty
heavily into the world of a vowed so all
of that will be familiar to returning
players we do start to see some of that
pillars Universe now in the avowed
setting which is really exciting and
it's looking amazing so far but can you
confirm one thing for me are we still in
aora we're still in aora and
specifically we're in a region called
The Living lands so again returning
pillars fans will recognize the living
lands as this otherworldly Frontier it's
very remote It's relatively unknown it's
this very dramatic landscape full of all
of these different valleys with these
unique biomes and creatures just a
really unique visual perspective and
it's a wonderful Frontier Z Spot that's
set for adventure there's a lot that's
undiscovered and so that's the part of
aora that we're introducing players to
in a vowed and we also see a character
talking to us in the trailer he seems
like he might be a companion because
that would be a very obsidian thing to
do so what's going on with that yes this
is Kai and he is one of the first
companions you made in the game he's an
amawa that's one of the unique species
of the world of aora and Kai is a
character brings a balance of this
really battle-hardened perspective he's
seen a lot he's served as a soldier and
a mercenary but he also has a really
unique sense of humor so he brings a
spirit of levity and camaraderie to the
party as well and as he's talking to us
he's also kind of conveying well he's
straight up saying that he's afraid of
you and your abilities but it's not like
the heroes are the only powerful beings
in this universe so I'm curious what
that means for who we are as the player
character are we a watcher again like in
Pillars one and two or maybe we have
some connections to the spirit realm and
beyond that gives us these terrifying
abilities so you're not a watcher this
time but you do have a unique Soul
connection to the world that gives you a
connection to the living lens and to
some of the more mysterious forces that
work there the player is also being sent
as an Envoy of the adirin Empire and so
they come with both a very mysterious
Aura but also a certain sense of
political urgency Kai also mentions a
plague that's another bit of detail that
we get within the trailer see a very
concerning growth on a lot of the
creatures in the world what can you tell
us about this plague I can't say too
much just yet except that it is a unique
Soul plague that is devouring the living
lands and part of the player's Mission
and being sent here is to investigate
and try to stop it we also saw a lot of
combat in the trailer and we see dual
wielding pistols we see spells we see
swords we see just a ton of abilities a
lot that actually is really reminiscent
of the pillars Universe too but those
were isometric top-down view games and a
vowed as a first person game so how did
the team approach that same kind of
fantasy combat but in the first person
for about so we wanted to take that same
depth and breadth of play Styles and
combat abilities and player fantasies
where you can play someone who's very
magically attuned more traditional
fighter or Ranger and really invest in
whatever play style is most appealing to
you personally we wanted to take that
depth and breadth and translate it into
a first-person experience where you can
feel the visceral nature of the attacks
feel the dynamism and the momentum of
those attacks and you're executing them
and that means including a range of
options like as you noted dual wielding
pistols which is one of my favorites
because you don't see that often in
fantasy RPGs but also traditional sword
and board a whole host of magical
abilities a lot of things it'll be both
a little bit familiar but hopefully new
to players as well and I've got one more
question for you because I know the
audience is going to want to know this
one but just how big is this game so
it's going to be roughly comparable to
something like Knights of the Old
Republic 2 or the outer worlds it is set
up as a series of interconnected open
zones that players can explore at their
own pace you can invest in discovering
every nook and cranny in the world
discovering every secret finding every
side quest meeting every character or
you can have a much more focused
experience and it's really up to players
and how much time they want to spend in
the living lands but I'm hopeful that
they're going to spend a lot of time
with us once the valve releases well
count man is one of those players
because I definitely want to read and
hear every line of dialogue everything
everyone has to tell me and discover
every inch of the living lands well
thank you again so much for being here
Carrie this has been so insightful and
fun thank you Tina this has been a
pleasure that was just a taste of what
you can expect from Obsidian
Entertainment when a vowed lands next
year on Xbox PC and Game Pass
[Music]
what's the descendants
my sister
Baltimore
foreign
[Music]
of making a game that was hopeful that
it was a Triumph for the human Spirit
something that had a lot of Replay
ability something that you can really
explore for for a long time there are
different worlds that we want to explore
towerborne is that game
towerborn is a fast-paced action RPG
it's a co-op game you can play online
you can play it on the couch with your
friends and family everybody's moving
through the world map together as the
players move out they start rig crumbing
the storyline that is being told here
from the world map you go into fun fast
combat
you come out of that with resources and
crafting items and with all their new
Loop they can go back to the belfry
but Belfry is the Players Safe Haven and
Humanity's Safe Haven the player can
customize their appearance their load
out talk to all these different NPCs the
world itself is a mix of 3D in in 2D we
definitely wanted to have that kind of
beautiful background that you see in
animated movies
powerborn is all about Humanity's last
chance at survival humanity is clinging
to Hope and clinging to this Tower
it is your mission to try to hold the
forces of Darkness at Bay to give
Humanity a chance at survival
the most important thing about the
gameplay is just it's just fun and it
kind of just Amplified its fun the
moment you added another player all of
the players can build their character in
a way that's specific to them just turns
into this back and forth exploration
like let's try to do this one combo and
then let's see if you can do a follow-up
from a couch Co-op perspective that's
just really fun because there's not too
many couch co-op games anymore
[Music]
I'm hoping in five years from now it's
in a place that I never even would have
thought of it's a seasonal game which is
different for us players can expect a
new storyline with new quests new biomes
we'll be rolling out new gear new
monsters new bosses expanding on the
content in a in a continuous organic way
so it just becomes a living world
[Music]
yeah when we started snowic we decided
let's just make games that we feel
strongly about and we want to play we
had to find the right relationship with
a publisher and I think we found that
with Xbox they've enabled us to make the
game that we want to make here
I earnestly cannot wait for the
community to see the game that we're
rolling out here towerborne is I I
really believe something unique
[Music]
there's that Roar again
what the hell is that thing
foreign
[Music]
hello I'm John Rush art director for
Fallout 76.
I hope you enjoyed the world premiere of
the trailer for our once in a blue moon
update coming June 20th free to play for
anyone who owns Fallout 76.
the blue moon has risen over the hills
of Appalachia bringing with it a ton of
great new content for players
that includes new Cryptids like the blue
devil and ogwa to threaten the progress
of the Blue Ridge Caravan company
we've also got two new public events
both of which give you a chance to earn
Caravan encrypted themed Rewards
defend the middle Mountain pit stop from
waves of monstrous creatures safe and
sound
and thwart a horde of crazed cultists
and peace of Burden
season 13 we've also got a new
scoreboard called shoot for the stars
celebrates the stars of the Silver
Screen
and gives you a chance to earn Cinema
themed Rewards
[Music]
and we're not done yet
next year we're taking players to
Atlantic City
where they'll gamble on the fates of new
factions for the opportunity to win big
do your part in helping the Blue Ridge
Caravan company
words along the way
once in a blue moon is coming June 20th
Appalachia is coming at you we'll see
you there
[Music]
what's this
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we've just seen a new trailer for
updates coming to HiFi Rush called
arcade challenge update no joke there's
literally exclamation points in there
that's not just me so here to explain
that and more about the update is game
director John Johannes welcome to
Showcase extended John really glad to be
here exclamation points
they have to be in there yeah it feels
the style it's style yeah style thing
well Hi-Fi Rush is such a stylish game
in general I think that's one of the
things that people really excitedly
pointed out when we Shadow dropped the
game in the developer direct earlier
this year but making a brand new IP is
always a bit of a risk your studio is
known for kind of scarier games like The
Evil Within and ghostwire Tokyo can't
deny that
um but yeah this type of game is
something I just always wanted to make
personally and I just thought music and
action work so well together and after I
had finished working on the evil within
two it just felt like the right time to
try something new and our studio has
always been about just making fun games
it doesn't have to be about a certain
genre we're not about making one
specific thing unfortunately there's
plenty more of that content to come
because we just saw an absolutely
jam-packed trailer so I'd love for your
help in breaking down all the details
all the stuff going into this update
sure there's a lot so bear with me
everything in this mode is unlockable
once you finish the game and you'll
unlock an arcade cabinet in your hideout
and by accessing it you get two new
modes one is called BPM Rush mode which
takes the gameplay up to like higher
speeds than we've ever done in the main
game and the other is called power up
Tower up which is a new sort of
randomized spin on the Rhythm Tower mode
that we have in the original game and
included in this mode are five new
original songs to play do as well as two
brand new enemies and then there's
special attacks and this whole meta
system for unlocking upgrades and
rewards and that's all I can think of
right now I love that there's so much to
to unpack there but let's rewind let's
talk about just BPM rush for now sure it
was described in the trailer as
effectively Hi-Fi Russia's equivalent of
a turbo mode can you explain that a
little bit more yeah early on the team
was like how fast can we go and in the
game we kind of settle that you know
about a Max 160 BPM but this mode really
takes it up to 200 BPM but we sort of
ease you in there it's a gradual upgrade
until it eventually gets so fast you
just gotta sort of think on your feet
and naturally react to the Rhythm in the
combat of the game I personally love
that there's a lot of accessibility
settings in the game too makes it so
that you can adjust the game to your own
Comfort level but this is a post game
challenge it's meant for when you've
gotten into the rhythm of the game so
I'm curious if you have any pointers on
as far as how to tackle that challenge
as an action game I think a lot of
people want that sort of next level
challenge another way to use their
abilities in a new type of environment
this mode does that by putting you at
the high speed but we also have multiple
difficulties we have an easy mode for
people who want to experience what
that's like but maybe are not in tune
with that sort of high difficulty that's
accompanied with this stuff but then we
have a casual normal mode as well and
then we have after beating those modes
we can unlock an ex mode which takes up
to a hard level where damage is
Multiplied and keeps you at that high
BPM throughout the entire time but there
already was a post game challenge when
Hi-Fi Rush launched it was the Rhythm
Tower mode you mentioned that briefly
earlier that's the one where you face
just increasingly different difficult
combat so how has that evolved with the
power of power up mode so the Rhythm
Tower mode was kind of like a very
curated experience and while it was very
challenging you can prepare go in and
sort of customize your character know
what you're getting into and in this
mode we flip it to the almost opposite
end chai starts off downgraded we
actually remove all your abilities and
you have to earn them back by fighting
waves of randomized enemy sets and after
every wave of enemies you get to choose
from a series of power-ups that can
gradually increase your stats each of
these upgrades comes with either bonus
or negative modifiers as well to the
gameplay so you can take more risks or
less risks depending on which upgrades
you pick and again those upgrades are
randomized each level so really kind of
an understanding of the systems and not
quite Master them but have a good grasp
if you want to go in and come out on top
well as I mentioned earlier it was a
really packed trailer there was a lot of
information in there it's a chunky
update so what else have you got for us
because I feel like there's more on the
table there yeah so by playing in the
two modes you unlock these rewards to
these challenges that are connected to
these two modes and in those rewards are
things like accessories for chai and new
costumes for chai 808 and even as well
as fan favorite Corsica we have new
modes for the photo mode as well things
like new filters we have new poses for
the characters we have stickers you can
place on the photos Now and Then There
are some extra hidden secrets that we
don't want to give away right now which
uh as you know from our game we like to
hide in there and we like people to find
which is always fun and then in
conjunction with this release we're also
releasing a separate uh costume pack
which is a kind of take on what the
characters would look like if maybe this
game took place in a different time
period oh a little tease I like that and
there's some really fun fun looking
stuff in there so well thank you again
so much for coming out all the way from
Japan to Showcase extended John I'm
super glad to be here that's all we have
to share about the new update for Tango
Gameworks is Hi-Fi Rush coming soon now
it's time for us to return to the second
air of Tamriel in the Elder Scrolls
Online Cinemax online Studios debuted
the trailer for their upcoming expansion
at Showcase and today they're here to
break that trailer down for us let's
hear what the team has to say about the
necron expansion for Elder Scrolls
Online
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching the Xbox showcase I'm rich
Lambert the creative director on Elder
Scrolls online and I'm CJ greb I'm the
project art director for Elder Scrolls
Online
one of the really interesting things
about Elder Scrolls Online is it's
different than really any other game out
there it's not your typical level gated
world go anywhere you can explore in any
order you want to you really can hop in
at any moment play with anybody can play
any part of the game and any story
and of course I mean we're on Xbox game
pass you know the biggest open world RPG
on Xbox and if you're at all a fan of
Elder Scrolls
no places that you maybe have never gone
before in Elder Scrolls and do things
that you've never been able to do
there's so many different activities to
participate in housing
we've got lore hunting and Antiquity
right right there's the Dungeons and the
trials and you can of course always
revisit lands that you've been to before
we've got Skyrim Morrowind yeah and
they're different times you know we're
almost a thousand years in the past
come in by yourself coming with friends
but don't worry that you're ever not
going to have something to do because
there are Adventures everywhere you go
we had an awesome trailer during the
Showcase
necron Hermes Mora yeah what's it all
about rich Hamas Mora is this
Daedric god of knowledge he's not good
he's not evil he is just focused on
cataloging the world and collecting
everything he possibly can to study and
what you kind of see in the trailer is
more a kind of always on guard always
looking over and watching what's kind of
going on and you get to see some
nostalgia in there as well from the
Dragonborn DLC in Skyrim with the yellow
green Skies vast Inky sea the stacks of
books I'll still never forget the first
time you showed us the initial concepts
for everything made out of books I
remember looking at that going oh my God
how are we going to do it how is this
gonna run
we always try to honor the past right
because when we go back to areas that
people who play Elder Scrolls games have
played they know these lands we want
them to feel like they're coming home
right but we have the chance to to add a
little into the mix
the art team was able to really play
with kind of cool unique monsters yeah
we were given some great places to go
for new monsters in the zone
we were looking at making a creature
that would kind of freeze you in Terror
as soon as you saw it and a creature
that has a deeper connection to the
overall story of The Zone we've also got
the tavani peninsula kind of the
Morrowind Vibe it's always fun to go
back to this part of Tamriel because
it's it's one of the most imaginative
and sort of like visually expressive
things that has ever been created for in
a little squirrels world and then of
course necron City itself this ancient
city that you know is rumored to have
been built you know even before the
tribunal was even established right
being able to play with that and look at
that architecture and this ancient city
of the dead and you guys gave us a new
class to do The Arcanist draws their
powers from Hamas Mora we really
challenged ourselves and the team to
make something that didn't feel like
anything else that we have built
everything we've been talking about
sounds amazing but when do we actually
get to play it necron launches on Xbox
June 20th and we can't wait for
everybody to get in there and see this
amazing content that we've created
thanks everyone for uh watching us
during the Showcase and watching us
today
lots of exciting stuff coming for ESO in
the future we'll see you on Tamara
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
watching
games
yes
dinosaur
s
foreign
hearings
congratulations
foreign
energy chakra
maximum
is
[Music]
aside
foreign
I got a call from my good friend jorg
Newman the head of Microsoft flight
simulator he told me about this once in
a lifetime out of this world opportunity
so I'm here in Budapest the capital of
Hungary York he's around here somewhere
let's go find him
work
Hey Paris it's great to see you great to
see you thanks for coming to Budapest of
course what am I doing here I'll tell
you on the way we have a board to catch
a boat yep we don't have a plane nope
come on Paris
[Music]
what is this place what kind of aircraft
are you storing in here dude it's much
cooler than that
all right Paris are you ready for this
you know I'm ready for this all right
let's go
[Music]
welcome to the world of Doom this is
incredible
come on I want you to meet someone
hey how's it going how are you man it's
good to see you see you
Paris I would like to introduce Patrice
Vermette Academy award-winning
production designer of Dune it is very
nice to meet you I'm a huge fan of Dune
now Patrice can you tell me what is this
place well this is the warehouse where
we actually keep most of the props and
the setback elements that we used on
doing part one and part two
New York how did all this get started so
it goes back to November 2021
Dune had just hit the movie theaters
worldwide and we got a car from
legendary and they had the idea that we
bring an ornasabda into Microsoft flight
simulator
and me being a lifelong science fiction
reader and fan a big huge fan of the
Frank Herbert books how could I say no
okay now it makes sense after seeing the
trailer at the Xbox showcase I
understand why you brought me here you
guys want to take a look because we
actually do have a couple of Ernie
doctors here if you want to see you want
to take a look that would be awesome
yeah let's do it all right let's do it
all right
[Music]
look at this
it's a one-on-one wheel size the one
that's up there it's amazing sure thank
you the knee likes things to be
plausible so that's why they were built
to look military rugged
and stealth now here's the most
important question where they built to
fly
you mentioned because I've been asked
that question a couple of occasions uh
no they don't fly they are heavy they're
11 tons so you're you have to get this
working in the game how did you do this
in Flight soon yeah it was actually
interesting so in in general honest
optos can fly and do fly this particular
one given that it weighs 11 tons that's
going to be a little bit harder
specifically because it's not really
doing the owners of the bird flap it
does oscillation of the blades and we
currently don't have the material
science to get the thrust and the lift
but on the Rockers I think this is
absolutely possible that flight Sim we
made it work Patrice we're here
can we go in absolutely all right let's
do it normally we'd go in through the uh
climbing up the landing gear but I guess
we'll do
yeah so what's cool about this Paris is
that all those buttons are actually
realistically hooked up to the system
Master engine switch what you're doing
there above those the red are basically
all the lights and as you notice
um it's all analog because in the world
of Doom there's no thinking machines
thinking machines have been illegal for
10 000 years that was actually a
fascinating when we implemented it we
because it's a science fiction we
thought oh it's glass cockpits
everything is going to be computerized
like none of it is this is a very
practical helicopter almost like from
the 1960s so jorg in the first movie the
popular was able to do a lot of cool
moves and Maneuvers you're going to be
able to reproduce that in Flight Sim oh
yeah totally I mean the really cool
design that you guys come up with is
each blade is independently controlled
so each blade has its own lift and
thrust and that means it can go from a
really stable hover to a steep dive and
back to a Glide instantaneously I would
just say thank you that you designed
such an awesome and realistic machine
because that's what we do we bring
realistic machines to life but if you
want to see a little bit more about the
game design I have something for you
absolutely I'd love to see
all right so the setup for this
expansion is that you are a tradies
pilot on a rockers flying in order
here is what we build
we basically build this section of a
ruckus here's the capital city of alkene
here's a Botanical Garden we have that
as well and the first thing we do is we
train you up the first takeoff fast
landing and then the Deep dive and then
we take you to some of the extreme
locations like above the cliff the hole
in the rock
the red Chasm you really have to show
your private skills and then towards the
end then there's a secret mission which
I can't talk about today but that
basically wraps up the experience it's
gonna be great super exciting hey it was
great to see you again
Paris
thank you for thank you so much for
having me
New York
where to next
well I don't know what they eat on the
Rockets but this is Budapest and I hear
they have excellent goulash I know a
place let's go
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Liza p is a thrilling Souls leg that
takes the story of Pinocchio turns its
on its head and sets it against the
Darkly elegant backdrop of The Bella
poke era
finally
we meet
you were awakened by a mysterious voice
you must adapt yourself and your weapons
to face Untold
untangle the unfathomable secrets of the
city's Elites and choose whether to
confront predicaments with the truth
or leave lies to overcome them on the
journey to find yourself
you are able to create your own weapon
through the combination of these blades
and handles of the hundreds of possible
combinations with different respective
appearances performances attack motions
and patterns
each and every blade and handle have
this distinctive Fable Arts Fable Arts
is a special combat skill that can be
casted by consuming Fable slots Fable
slots can be charged again through
combat select your own special skills to
Vanquish your enemies the legion arm is
a prosthetic on P's left arm the legion
arm can exhibit special abilities by
consuming the legion gauge providing you
an Eclectic combat experience
so puppets are all there are
I highly doubt that you'll have to face
all sorts of monsters puppets only being
one of them
you're not quite done yet bone chilling
bosses await you
if a boss seems too intimidating
you might want to get help from a
specter
in Boss matches you can summon a specter
that will assist you in battle with a
bit of help you will be able to defeat
bosses with more use
the P organ is a system that allows you
to upgrade your character use quartz to
optimize P to your liking within the P
organ you can select which slots to
unlock depending on your preference
there will be times when you will be
confronted with choices where you can
give Comfort to others and sorrow or
despair by lying or you can choose to
tell the truth
carve your own path
[Music]
me Liza p on Xbox One Xbox series and
game pass coming to you this September
19th
at the hearts of hellblade is our
ambition to sink you into cenova's world
and story to do this it's critical that
we make it as easy as possible for you
to suspend your disbelief one key method
of achieving this is our use of
performance capture
[Music]
foreign
what I want to achieve on stage is to
get the best performance and best
storytelling from the actors and then to
get that into the game as Faithfully as
possible I want to see what I saw on
stage in the game
lunch it's time to find when we were
shooting the scene from the Xbox
showcase it was quite a a somber mood on
set because that was one of our moments
in the game where it's just senower just
Center and the Furies and we have an
opportunity to connect with the player
one-on-one
are they
at this point in Santa's Journey she's
had her confidence eroded there's a lot
of doubt
and she needs to find within herself
a spark of of hope that strength that
she has
in order to continue on everything I've
done
just let me to this place we've come so
far while the scene is relatively simple
the scale and complexity of our
performance capture has multiplied to
meet our creative Ambitions on hellblade
2.
we shot the first help aid in the
boardroom of our old Studio it was very
MacGyver together in the new studio we
have a custom built mocap space which
has pretty much everything we could have
dreamed of we've got projectors so we
can recreate sets on the ground if we
need to we've got loads of props that we
have available to us at any time so we
can build sets
I remember coming in to interview and
seeing the setup down there and
immediately being impressed by
the clear commitment that had been made
to underpinning great true to life
performance with great quality data so
we've got a lot more cameras this time
around
um they're kind of top of the line at
the moment and in the kind of space that
we have downstairs we have nearly
wall-to-wall coverage which is really
impressive and it's not something that
is common it's certainly a step up from
a few cameras set up in a boardroom
with our setup we can push even further
on our ambition of bringing through as
much of our actors performances as
possible into the game even down to the
most nuanced of movements
so when you've got a optical system like
ours set up and calibrated well you can
track performance movements down to the
millimeter so we can see somebody
shuffling their finger along the table
or just wiggling them very gently you
can see hesitation and breath there's no
need to push the action and overact you
can just be your character
I'm here now
what we want is the best performance
possible the best immersion possible for
the player and that's why we go to these
lengths just to try and get that extra
Fidelity of performance into the game
what do you want me to do
with performance capture being at the
heart of our character movement our
props and staging had to facilitate our
vision I don't want to give any spoilers
away but there is going to be a boat in
the game
that boy will have several characters on
board we wanted to be able to capture
the motion of a boat across multiple
characters simultaneously
and we for the first time had the space
to be able to to construct a proper rig
for this so we had a platform which
could be moved in any number of ways to
create that kind of pitch in your role
that you would get on the ocean and we
got our actors up onto this boat and
captured scene with highways and a storm
and we've got incredible data from
really really amazing
the most important part of my role is to
make sure that story gets told
and having these wonderful actors we're
working with
bring their talents to bear on these
characters has been such an amazing
experience
[Music]
every year in our showcase there's one
game that kind of pops for me something
I'm very interested in this year we got
to announce 33 Immortals from Thunder
Lotus and I'm here now with Stefan and
will to walk through a demo of the game
which I've never played before first
time we have 33 people online incredibly
excited about this so we're going to
jump in
and start playing 33 Immortals is a
co-op action roguelike for 33 players
who play a damn Soul must rebel against
God's final judgment so there are three
of us here today on stage three upstairs
and 27 people joining us from Montreal
in the studio hi everyone and we are
ready that's us everybody's spawning in
that's us
this is 33 player multiplayer yeah not a
normal number of characters for a
multiplayer game yeah how did you come
up with 33 players we were searching for
a significant number where we can all
play on the screen yeah we stay together
on the screen so 33 felt good 32 felt
good but as the game is inspired by the
Divine committee uh the medieval poem
from Dante Ali Jerry weekend in the 14th
century and this poem has three section
Inferno together
each section has 33 chapters and so we
say oh let's do 33
Immortals man I love what you said well
that when you guys started this game
there weren't even 33 people at the
studio so you didn't have enough people
in the studio to fill out the full
roster of the game yeah which is such an
awesome point it's a challenge it's a
challenge when you're trying to do that
I love it okay so no two ones are the
same we're actually spinning in a
different position a different situation
we are in the cemetery if you own the
left trigger so one map is going to show
up ah and we can see that we are 33
right now actually in Inferno which we
are scattered around the world oh we're
not all in the same place yeah yeah
because we all have to complete torture
chambers got it to make the game
progress okay and we are located at the
south west of Inferno yeah and so the
closest torture chambers is to the east
okay so let's go there got it
okay let's continue down south towards
the first third Chambers
this one I have a good feeling for it
the uh soundtrack what's going on the
music's kind of cool oh thank you this
is uh Max LL who's actually done the
music on all of our games
and you're in Montreal we are in
Montreal yes close to one of our xgs
studios in compulsion yes it's also in
showcase yes I love the community of
game creators in Montreal absolutely
It's always important to be uh well
surrounded and all that so we didn't
talk about your first game Spirit Fair
yeah I loved I thought it was fantastic
thank you yeah it was great
now as you can see uh this is not Spirit
Fair
how about that from a studio standpoint
having such I mean I would say they're
stylized games but yeah outside of that
very different games we're not worried
about you know genre our goal is really
to just try and make unique immersive
creative experiences that players love
and that they want to play for
awesome I love that yeah
this guy is
getting out of my comfort zone sometimes
oh all right what do we do so we have
completed a hotel chamber so we have
achieved our first step I got left
behind that's what you're saying good
yeah oh they're back on us ah whoa well
we got to face the ref of good careful
oh
[Music]
yeah
I have like zero health
new torture no I gotta get out of here
where are you all right
well why weren't they in the torture
table trying to help us okay these range
uh good is getting angry yeah
we're getting hammered right now
come on okay here's a guy can you revive
me yeah yeah just stop moving that's
good come on come on up yeah I'm up I'm
up okay false thank you oh no oh
this is
now we're in Holy Fire
the wrath of God okay I'm ahead of it
okay so we unlocked the actions in
battle so that's the last battle yes can
people jump in my heels yeah yeah yeah I
mean I mean
a dragon video
don't mind me the wandering soul I
should save me please like a zombie
maybe someone I mentioned I'd never
played before
[Laughter]
I died too ah okay hopefully the team
the team can carry us
there's a lot of enemies in this small
space I'm gonna try to not move okay
don't move and hopefully someone is
going to be able to revive you okay good
all right okay
okay I'm back yeah yeah thank you
so this is the last step I think it's my
life all right
okay yeah we did it yeah we did it yeah
well yeah we did it yeah yeah
so now we've ascended yeah that was
first chapter of first book Is that how
I should think about it yeah it's the
first world uh so it's Inferno yeah uh
and
um yeah each region has its whole big
set of challenges and everything and
this is all on the map and it's final
boss fight that's what this is well
since we've basically come through
unscathed so far this should be easy
thank you
okay
you saved us from having to kill the
final boss
it's a bit of a tease ah I like it I
like it well best of luck to you and the
team and everything that's going on
can't wait for this game to come out I
won't ask for the date because I know
that's unfair but it was great to have
in the show and great for you to come
down and we got the opportunity to play
so thank you thank you so much thank you
so much for having us thanks for
watching showcase extended I love these
opportunities to show more about
everything that you saw in the in the
Showcase itself thanks to everybody that
supported us and have a great week
thanks everybody
[Music]
foreign